[Musique]
lan il ya quelques jours je vous ai
présenté hop on disait il ya quelques
jours je vous ai présenté le samsung
galaxy s 10 ans à plus de présenter on
l'a présenté il ya déjà quelques temps à
londres je vous ai des bulles et publiés
montrent est bien évidemment sur youtube
et aujourd'hui il est l'heure de parler
vous l'aurez vu dans le titre de la
vidéo vous avez cliqué donc vous savez
c'est pas un secret mais il est quand
même là c'est le galaxy s 10e alors j'ai
déjà plein de ghosting et quelques temps
on part commence aujourd'hui
et justement ce petit galaxy s dit ce
petit parce que petit format mais là
tout d'un grand
il est là il est beau il est chaud il
est sympa il est en blanc il est
magnifique et il est vraiment
intéressant je suis très content parce
que cette année samsung
vous voulez un petit peu plus élargir sa
gamme est en train de remodeler la gamme
notamment sur l'entrée milieu de gamme
bon sens on leur parlera plus tard la
gamma mais pour l'instant on va vraiment
se concentrer sur cette gamme s
on a parlé du s10 plus qui peut le plus
peut le moins c'est exprès de pas vous
parler du s10 aller directement sur le
modèle le plus haut de gamme qui est
juste 1 1 ici par contre ils ont sorti
un tout nouveau modèle qui est vraiment
très intéressant c'est celui là
le s10 se forme à 5,8 pouces je vais pas
dire format pocket mais presque parce
que on voit que les écrans deviennent de
plus en plus grand sur le smartphone
plus de 6 pouces et au final les
personnes qui aiment les format un peu
plus petit aujourd'hui le 5e 10 pouces
et le voyais un format un peu plus petit
et bien ils ont ce smartphone là c'est
assez bizarre de dire qui informait de
5,8 pouces en format pocket mais au
final la problématique se passe souvent
pour poser son smartphone dans des
petites poches dans un sac à main un 5,8
pouces sera beaucoup plus pratique qu'un
écran beaucoup plus grand
forcément vous en douterez donc ça c'est
plutôt cool nouvelle prise de position
de la part de samsung sur ce format là
on va faire un tour complet ça fait
quelques jours que je n'utilise que j'ai
avec moi et franchement il est très
intéressant on pourrait se dire un
modèle essentiel s10e eux pour essentiel
et pas économie on va donc à l'essentiel
on met le meilleur de ce qu'on peut
retrouver chez samsung là dedans sans
fioritures je veux pas dire que le fait
d'aller sur un produit beaucoup plus
haut de gamme pas beaucoup plus calmes
avec beaucoup plus de d'options c'est
plus ça sur le modèle plus c'est de la
fioriture mais là dessus on se concentre
sur l'essentiel pour moi que ce 10e il
ya trois questions essentielles à
laquelle je vais essayer de répondre
aujourd'hui
premier point à qui il s'adresse
deuxième point vaut-il le coup et
troisième point faut-il acheter
en fait d'une petite aparté au sujet de
cette statue là dont on a parlé le jo la
statuette de truck
alors je vous explique tout de suite je
ne suis pas du tout fan de donald trump
on va pas faire une critique politique
aujourd'hui
mais et c'est trop marrant tu peux
regarder je pense que ça s'exprime
vraiment le positionnement de trump
voyez ce qui vous fait un bisou donc
voilà c'est ça me fait marrer c'est pour
ça qu'il ya dans le décor non pas pour
faire l'apologie du président du res bas
ceci étant dit on passe à autre chose
ce galaxy s2 je trouve vraiment bien
déjà en termes de prise en main de ce
que je vous disais ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est ce format 5,8 pouces il
tient très facilement dans la main on
peut l'utiliser à une main et saké coule
pas la différence de forme en un peu
plus grand ou lorsqu'on veut aller
appuyer un peu plus bas tout voyage non
c'est compliqué il faut le prendre à
demain pour venir le stabiliser
celui là une main vous avez accès
facilement à tout votre écran coulon
déjà pour moi ça s'est vraiment bien
ce format est idéal vous mettez dans une
poche très facilement il est léger il
fait à peine 150 g et en plus je trouve
vraiment très jolie autre plan que
j'adore vraiment là-dessus
c'est alors on n'est pas un truc tout
neuf ce que je vais dire c'est vraiment
le capteur d'empreintes digitales bouton
je sais qu'aujourd'hui on a de la
reconnaissance à sa chaîne en trois
dimensions notamment chez apple on
allait capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique ou alors capteur
d'empreintes digitales
c'est pas forcément ultrasonique sous
l'écran a forcément ce qu'ils valent
plus vite par contre moi j'adore ce
petit système de capteur d'empreintes
digitales positionner sur la tranche
vous positionnez vos doigts dessus sa
part directement et ça je trouve ça
vraiment très intéressant ça va vite
très réactif ça pour moi c'est
aujourd'hui une des meilleure
intégration qu'on puisse avoir le design
vraiment cool avec le dos en verre qui
est très jolie alors se doit en vert on
va pas se mentir il faut se protéger
parce que tout de suite vous risquez de
l'endommager de l'abîmé et ça serait
vraiment dommage moi ce que je vous
conseille vraiment là-dessus
c est de mettre une coque de protection
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout accessoire
c'est très important comme je lé mise
sur mon galaxy s 10 plus exactement je
vous parlais de rhinau chine avec qui je
travaille ça vous le savez depuis
quelques temps j'aime bien leur produit
se trouve intéressant ils ont une gamme
qui est assez sympa alors il ya plein de
produits cool qu'il existe chez eux des
protections d'écran anti chien qui vous
recommande vraiment pour protéger
l'avant de votre smartphone et puis pour
l'ariège vous avez les souliers de suite
alors il ya les modèles en carbone vous
avez des modèles un peu plus classique
enfin je trouve ça vraiment pas mal et
je ne peux que vraiment vous conseiller
d'aller protéger votre smartphone et
d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse vous
avez un lien avec un code promo de 10%
dans la description trop de poids qui
est vraiment intéressant sur ce
smartphone c'est la qualité de l'écran
je trouve extrêmement lumineux on
connaît le savoir-faire de samsø au
niveau des écrans avec samsung display
ils font des écrans qui sont vraiment
superbes très belle qualité très belle
colorimétrie très belle luminosité ça
s'est extrêmement bien maîtrisé j'ai
déjà parlé du côté un peu configuration
avec le filtre lumière bleue avec le
mode nuit vous invite à aller voir ma
vidéo sur de test du samsung galaxy s 10
plus vous verrez tout comme ça je vais
pas vous refaire un petit peu le pitch
aujourd'hui pour regarder des vidéos sur
youtube sur netflix et couleurs après
fois que je veux un petit peut être un
peu moyen moyen c'est effectivement la
petite bulle parce que malgré tout quand
vous regardez vos vidéos la bulle elle
est là
il existe on ne joue pas ça me dérange
beaucoup moins d'avoir une petite bulle
là dessus sur son s10e que la grosse
bulle ici directement sur le s10 plus
qui cachait là après si elle vous
dérange vous prenez votre smartphone
vous le mettez à l'envers et c'est vrai
que tout de suite on la voit un petit
peu moins mais un peu moins dérangeante
et puis surtout ce qui est bien dessus
c'est l'audio vous avez un haut parleur
ici son côté vous avez un deuxième
haut-parleurs ici deuxième haut parleurs
va être beaucoup moins puissante par
contre ce qui est vachement bien c'est
pour le côté l'immersion vous n'êtes
plus dans votre vidéo il ya plus
d'immersion et c'est là où on voit que
ce smartphone est essentielle
il garde l'essentiel du meilleur de la
technologie même s'il n'y a pas tout il
est franchement très bien et ça me
souvenais pas venus rogner en termes de
qualité pour vous permettre de gagner au
niveau du prix créa sujet se passe le
bonjour à mathilde chez samsung
le smartphone est aussi puissant vous
avez à l'exynos 9820 c'est exactement le
même sauf que vous retrouvez dans le s10
plus si jia drame
il est fluide il est rapide pratique
pour jouer à des jeux tout ce que vous
voulez en plus vous avez deux versions
en stockage 128 giga ou 256 giga
extensible donc à smartphones
performants smartphone avec un bel écran
un smartphone vous pouvez mettre pas mal
de choses dedans déjà voyez on est dans
l'essentiel dans l'essentiel hyper haut
de gamme ça c'est vraiment intéressant
question très importante qu'en est-il de
l'autonomie vous avez une batterie de
3100 au million père heures pour être
très clair très transparent ce
smartphone en autonomie moindre par
rapport au s 10 plus par contre ça fera
la faire c'est toujours compliqué de
vous parler d'autonomie parce que ça
dépend des usages si vous achetez ce
smartphone mais je peux pas vous
garantir vous allez le garder deux jours
ça va vraiment dépendre de vous ce que
vous allez en faire par contre moi par
rapport à mon utilisation je le garde ou
une journée ou une journée une mise si
je pousse un peu mais au bout d'une
journée me il faut leur charge et parce
que sinon ça ne nuira pas je ne le garde
pas de jour par contre une journée sans
problème que vous avez bien évidemment
de la recharge en usb type s'est par
contre ce n'est pas une recharge rapide
vous prévoyez un petit peu de temps pour
le recharger voudra changer tous les
soirs vous serez tranquille doit
absolument aucun problème
autre point hyper important sur ce
smartphone c'est la partie photo vidéo
on a un double capteur est pas un triple
capteurs comme on pourrait avoir sur le
s10 plus
néanmoins il fait vraiment bien la faire
vous avez un double objectif 12
mégapixels qui ouverture variable f1
points 5 f 2.4 comme vous avez pu
retrouver les dernières sur le s9 s9
plus et le note 9 et ont un deuxième
objectif c'est un 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.2 c'est un ultra
grand-angle et à l'avant vous avez dans
votre bulle une caméra de 10 mégapixels
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir sur
cette partie appareil photo déjà ce
qu'il faut retenir hiatus excellent
smartphone qui est excellent en
conditions de bonne luminosité
dès lors que les conditions sont
optimales les photos sont très très cool
vous avez de la reconnaissance de scène
là vous êtes sûre du sushi shop à ce que
ça vous aura pas échappé photo normale
grand angle voyez la différence ça
marche franchement bien la colorimétrie
est légèrement différente mais ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne c'est
légèrement plus pâle un peu moins de
détails avec le grand chose c'est vrai
que la caméra principale à 12,06 elle
sera meilleure par contre ce que vous
pouvez faire avec le grand angle c'est
très sympa les couleurs sont naturels on
a vraiment du détail prévenir ou même
petit peu dans l'image en g les carreaux
là au niveau du métro
c'est plutôt cool pour voir qu'on est
quand même dans le métro donc c'est pas
avoir les meilleures conditions de
luminosité et comme je le disais quand
vous êtes dehors le rendu est juste
topissime c'est très très proche de ce
que vous avez en réalité de ce que
j'habite dans l'assiette à ce moment là
et si vous aimez la viande c'est un fin
gras du mézenc ça donne vraiment envie
pareil sur un autre photo de places
russes qu'ossa donne faim se donner
envie c'est plutôt cool et quand vous
arrivez sur les photos de nuit le gros
lot est plutôt bien fait s'est pas
complètement extraordinaire on n'est pas
à la hauteur d'un ait 20 pro et d'un
pixel 3 envoyé cette photo là haut avec
le grand angle mais malgré tout le rendu
est plutôt cool garder les points de
détails lorsque je viens zoom et un
petit peu dans l'image le job est fait
c'est correct là si vous regardez les
lumières vous verrez la différence par
rapport à un pixel 3 ou un mec 20 pro on
voit que ce n'est pas complètement
optimisé dans la partie là où vous avez
les lumières par contre on voit bien
tout le reste les détails là au niveau
de la cathédrale ça marche mais là c'est
quand même un petit peu cramé c'est là
où on voit un peu les limites de ce
smartphone en termes de photos nuit là
voulaient avec le grand-angle c'est
forcément déformant mais les faits quand
même sympa pour trouver la même chose là
c'est pas mal mais quand vous arrivez en
bas sur les lampadaires c'est un petit
peu cramé et c'est là où on voit toutes
les limites de ce traitement logiciel
saas et la photo est l'objectif de 12
mégapixels et l'abri sur le 16
mégapixels grand-angle là on est sur un
shooting et le joint d'un événement pour
panasonic
regardez là typiquement sur le boxeur on
peut venir ou mais alors là on commence
à voir plus de pixels contre va vraiment
chercher loin dans le zoom mais sinon là
vous mettez comme ça le rendu il est
franchement top ça marche vraiment bien
vous pouvez faire le mode portrait que
la caméra avant et la caméra arrière
pour moi le mode portrait que la caméra
arrière pour ce n'est plutôt pas mal de
courage est assez correcte même au
niveau des petits cheveux
bon alors après les jumeaux mais quand
même contre derrière donc c'est parce
qu'il va y avoir mieux mais je trouve
quand même que le rendu est plutôt bien
voyez que détourage entre les doigts au
niveau des vêtements ça fait plutôt bien
la faire par contre le mode portrait
vision des caméras de cette fille c'est
quand même moins ça voyez ici par
exemple qu'il a eu du mal avec les
vêtements derrière à venir le détour et
il me perds un petit peu la partie de
cheveux grise et parce que c'est un
petit peu la même trame de ce qu'on va
pouvoir retrouver derrière le traitement
est moins bien au niveau du doigt là
c'est pareil si beaucoup maclean ça va
me faire des choses avec mais c'est vrai
que bon c'est quand même beaucoup moins
obtient 10 et que la caméra arrière
forcément vous pouvez filmer ou 4k à 60
images par seconde mais si vous voulez
vraiment profité de la stabilisation
je pensais de filmer en full hd 30 ou 60
images par secondes et vous avez une
superbe stabilisation logiciels ça
marche parfaitement bien ça c'est une
vidéo où j'ai tourné le jour lors la
présentation du à 50 de samsung regardez
où est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on va
trôner ensemble à léon ce soir à l'ats
appelez moi je le slow je vous emmène
aujourd'hui dans un spot juste
incroyable pour parler de verdure de
voitures responsable électrique
on s'est installé à nissan leaf mais
chiant quand je passais tous les sens de
la bonne compagnie voilà alors vous avez
les aux radios
on a les bras j'ai juste ça voilà vous
voyez aujourd'hui je vais le spot ou
fille sim
[Musique]
il ya d'autres postes auxquels ce
smartphone est excellent je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure je vous parle
effectivement de l'audio vous avez les
haut parleurs stéréo
en plus de ça vous avez une prise jack
et conservait lorsque vous l'écouté au
casque avec un bon casque vous avez
vraiment une expérience qui est génial
l'audio et de grande qualité en plus
vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 peu utilisé
avec un casque à réduction de bruit moi
j'utilise avec mon sony monde wmx m3 le
son est juste magnifique
en plus de ça vous avez dû d'elle bien
tu n'oses de biens est une autre que peu
utilisé aussi pour le jeu vous avez à
d'absents d'absents que vous avez
différents profils en fonction de votre
âge donc ça c'est cool vous pouvez le
maître par défaut pour les régler pour
moins de 30 ans entre 30 ans et 60 ans
et pour plus de 60 ans moi je suis là 30
à 60 et voyez sur la perte d'audition
normal donc tout ce que vous avez en
bleu un peu grisé
c'est l'audition standard et tout ce qui
en bleu foncé c'est ce qui va être
récupérée par la partie logicielle donc
si vous regardez par exemple moins de 30
ans vous entendez bien tout est assez
haut mais dès que vous arrivez sur
trouve plus de 60 ans et bien votre
audition a b c est votre logiciel va
venir tout compenser vous profitiez
toujours de la même qualité
donc ça c'est vraiment bien en plus il
est compatible rds et à acea petit sa
fin c'est vraiment smartphones qui est
hyper hyper hyper cool pour l'audio pour
la vidéo l'écran et hop pour l'audio
c'est juste top pour les photos c'est
bien on peut avoir mieux avec un s dise
plus mais voyez on garde l'essentiel et
sait vraiment où l'adn de ce produit il
est également ip68 protéger contre les
éclaboussures contre la poussière
il ya du nfc avec samsung taille que
vous pouvez utiliser ça c'est aussi
intéressant
il ya pas mal de petites optimisations
logiciel également vous y retrouverez
sur l'écran latéral toutes vos
applications que vous utilisez le plus
assez aussi cool et il a un das 1,0581 2
watts par kilogramme
il est complètement dans les clous en
gros vous risquez pas de vous cramer le
cerveau avec néanmoins je pensais quand
même d'utiliser des oreillettes en
bluetooth ou alors en filaire c'est
toujours mieux idem j'aime bien être à
face wang wei ça je vous en avais déjà
parlé dans ma vidéo présentation du s10
plus one way qui est basé sur un android
9 paille qui tourne bien qui franchement
très intéressant vous avez pas mal de
choses avec toutes les parties de
bien-être numérique
vous allez pouvoir voir tout ce que vous
avez fait ça c'est ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui vous allez pouvoir retrouver
tout ce que vous avez utilisé de quelle
manière combien quoi comme en face à
part ça je trouve ça c'est cool ça coûte
un peu préventif
l'os est intéressant le smartphone est
optimisé c'est une belle réussite
bien des cours smartphones qui excellent
au niveau de l'écran au niveau de
l'audio au niveau de la photo il très
bon on n'est pas sur le meilleur
photophone mais franchement ce sens très
bien
c'est un bon produit la performance est
vraiment là l'autonomie est pas mal sur
une belle journée vous aurez pas de
soucis smartphone très équilibré que je
trouve vraiment très intéressant surtout
ce que j'aime c'est ce format compact je
sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous trouvez bien vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire
est ce que vous préférez ce format là où
est ce que le format du galaxy s 10 plus
c'est plus votre dada
moi j'aime bien celui là je retourne
vraiment aux smartphones avec des écrans
un peu plus petit on a effectivement des
peut-être détails un peu moins confort
pour regarder des vidéos que sur des
très grands smartphone comme ça mais
vous manipulez à une main c'est plutôt
cool ça c'est un avis très personnel
autant j'aime beaucoup je trouve que là
dessus samsung a fait vraiment un
excellent boulot donc à la question à
qui s'adresse ce smartphone
il s'adresse à ceux ou à celles qui
veulent à des smartphones exigeante avec
une belle fiche technique tu vas pouvoir
répondre à tous vos besoins sans ramer
avec une très belle qualité d'écran et
qui va être hyper réactif pour toutes
vos photos donc un smartphone vraiment
exigeant pour tous ceux qui veulent aux
smartphones exigeant ce samsung galaxy s
10e est juste parfait est ce qui vaut le
coup bien évidemment qui vaut le coup
faut-il acheter
si vous avez un smartphone qui est très
récent de l'année dernière par exemple
un galaxy s 9 s9 plus note 9 one le
smartphone haut de gamme la concurrence
je pense pas qu'il faille le changer
avant que vous voulez vraiment réduire
la taille et qu'au final la taille de
votre smartphone est encore grande si
vous voulez quelque chose d'un peu plus
petits là vous pouvez aller dessus on
est quand même sur un budget c'est un
smartphone qui n'est pas cadeau qui
coûte 759 euros
à quelque chose près des fois vous
pouvez trouver un peu moins cher
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse je vous
aime bien lien en bas dans la
description si par contre vous avez un
smartphone qui est un peu plus anciens
vous avez un smartphone qui n'est pas
aussi performant et que vous voulez plus
de performances plus de fluidité plus
d'exigence vous pouvez y aller parce que
je pense que le s10 ocs 10e essentiel
mais ça aurait pu être s10e exigeant
parce qu'il est très exigeant sans un
bon smartphone moi personnellement
j'adore dites moi si vous pourriez vous
l'achetez ce smartphone si vous le 1er
cru en plus ce qui est cool cette année
vous avez eu les galaxies bugs que j'ai
testé il ya pas très longtemps qu'ils
sont vraiment aussi excellent et qui
fonctionne parfaitement bien avec ce
smartphone dites-moi est-ce que vous en
pensez
que vous pouvez vous laisser tenter oui
non comment vous trouvez ce que vous
aimez lequel vous préférez entre le s10
plus et le s 10e et au final par rapport
à la concurrence comment vous le situer
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un bon
smartphone que c'est un bon choix
ou alors vous êtes un peu déçu vous
n'aimez pas trop la proposition vous
marquez tous arborent commentaires on en
parle ensemble
vous avez bien évidemment à consulter ma
playlist qui s'affiche par là où par là
qui vous parle de tous les smartphones
du moment de toute l'actu je navigue
bien évidemment à rester connectés parce
qu'on va les tester plein d'autres
smartphones plein d'autres produits on
va les rencontrer d'ici un ou deux jours
vous allez voir ça va être très
intéressant
je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et
à bientôt ciao
[Musique]